vor 40 jahren haben diese zwei
bankdirektoren erreicht was als
unmöglichkeit
sie löschen den inbegriff der schweiz zu
retten
die uhrenindustrie kunden heißt das es
im heizkessel müsse sofort zusätzlich
machen mit der banken- und da unten ist
mir enorm belasten
was war passiert das nicht mitgemacht
hatten da waren natürlich schlecht
schweiz anders als meine ganzen region
mehr an boden
ja und zwar lang am boden kleben sich
mehrere zehntausend insgesamt 80 er
benutzt musik mithalten
damit teilt einen zulieferbetrieb es ist
die größte und wichtigste rettungsaktion
sie
das ist friss oder stirb
wenn das abkommen nicht stankovic heute
blüht die schweizer uhrenindustrie auch
dank des uhren pionier jean claude biver
[Musik]
ganz neue blaue keramik farbe das ist
eine unglaubliche harmonie
die würde ich kaufen
[Musik]
schweizer uhren dominieren den weltmarkt
also heute sind wir stark wie vorher
erfolgreich dank einer jahrzehntealten
tradition die mechanische ist kultur
tradition kunst und ist ewig in 100
jahren wird diese uhr noch laufen
das und das ist was die leute heute
schätzen sie wollen nicht mehr mit der
option es zu tun haben sie wollen sie
sich an die zukunft an die ewigkeit
anknüpfen
die brauchen ewigkeit wir haben ja keine
mehr
und da siehst einen einen grund warum
wir so erfolgreich heute sind mit
mechanischen uhr 40 jahre vorher
[Musik]
krise resignation hoffnungslosigkeit die
schweizer uhrenindustrie vor den aus sie
beginnen einen beruf und fast jeden
morgen wissen sie nicht ob sie am
nächsten tag noch weiter arbeiten können
oder nicht
[Musik]
die angestellten lebten damals in einer
völlig unsicheren welt wir machen uns
große sorgen
[Musik]
wenn man schon im netz schaufelte
unseren starts wirtschaft und märkte
kündigung bekommen sich verrucht firmen
stellen
[Musik]
sexy cora nie dafür zu schaffen
im moment ist das für uns wie ein
schwarzes loch
alle fragen sich was kann ich tun wohin
kann ich gehen muss sich diese region
verlassen
und da wir fast alle hier in diesen
bergen und tälern geboren sind möchten
wir natürlich hier bleiben
[Musik]
es war ein schiff der in eine riesige
sturm stand und alle hatten angst
alle wollten vom schiff runter kein
mensch war in der lage zu sagen kommt
kinder also das schiff ist am kentern
wir haben riesige wellen eventuell
sterben wir alle aber jetzt tun wir
mindestens wie männer sterben tun wir
dieses schiff unter kontrolle nehmen und
sehen wir was wir daraus machen können
ich wusste ganz genau dass wir in der
schweiz wenn wir ein produkt herstellen
können 1 uhr mit weniger als sieben oder
zehn prozent direktor und kosten hunter
dass wir alle andere schlagen kann
die swatch der eine ausweg aus der krise
wer als im studio die beide swatch
faktor 11 in der küstenstadt müller und
elmar motto sicher ist die begeisterung
von jungen ingenieuren damals herr bock
spezialisiert in kunststoffe und ich
spezialisiert seit über zehn jahren in
uhrwerken diese begegnung von zwei
welten kreierte die swatch so lautet die
zusammenfassung wissen sie im leben
benötigt man chancen
man muss sie natürlich auch ergreifen
das ist kurz gesagt die geburt der
berühmten swatch
[Musik]
jean claude biver ehe welt in der krise
einen anderen ausweg
es war eine tragödie ich habe es zuerst
ein schmerz aber ich hab's auch auf der
anderen seite gut erlebt denn ich habe
profitiert um plötzlich ebendieser in
diesem wechseln wo alles in die zukunft
ging nur zukunft wir verlassen die
vergangenheit verbrechen die
vergangenheit werfen sie weg das heißt
keine mechanische uhren mehr nur mit
quartz zukunft zukunft und ich habe
gesagt da gibt's auch einen weg
rückwärts innovativ zu wehren
heute weiß dass er richtig entschieden
hat sind sehr gute ergebnisse + 2 30
prozent gegenüber dem letzten jahr also
ist schon erfreulich ich bin sehr
zufrieden dass sie in gute nachricht von
zeit zu zeit muss man die auch mitteilen
hast du dann
mitten in der krise kauft song claude
biver eine alte traditionsmarke für ein
butterbrot
als niemand mehr an das überleben der
uhrenindustrie glaubt hat er eine vision
wir beschäftigen uns schon mit der
ewigkeit und ewigkeit ist was ist ewig
lieber ist ewig die künstler kunst ist
ewig picasso kann nicht sterben
moser kann nicht sterben die beatles
kann auch nicht sterben
das heißt das waren unsere ideen
[Musik]
juni ist und wir haben uns gefragt liebe
liebe ist ewig aber nicht nur die liebe
zwischen zwei menschen liebe ist eine
moralische attitüden und dann weil ich
natürlich hatte eine leidenschaft für
uhren
das ist ewig in den ohren nicht kurz wir
wussten dann in dieser zeit gingen
wurden die batterien immer schmaler
dünner kleiner und natürlich nach zehn
jahren konnte man die batterien nicht
mehr kaufen weil die batterie hat er war
wirklich kleiner geworden und plötzlich
hatte die batterie kein märchen sondern
sie haben es jugend- und dann wurde ließ
ihm verboten und das haben wir alles
gesehen und wir haben das gewusst
[Musik]
und da haben wir immer darauf gespielt
ähnlichkeit ist amerikanischen ist
regelt sie ist das kind eines harry das
eines erbe er sie ist das kind einer
tradition sie ist das kind einer kunst
kunst luxus erfolg vor 40 jahren in
dieser krise unvorstellbar diese
wiedergeburt der mechanischen uhr in
dieser masse hätte ich nie gedacht
ein bisschen schon weil mit glaube habe
das ja gemacht aber dass plötzlich alle
macht dar wie sie heißen wiederkommen
mit mechanischer das hätte ich nie
gedacht und hätte das gedacht
sonst hätten wir die werkzeuge nicht
weggeworfen denn in den achtziger jahren
haben wir so stark gedacht dass das nie
wieder kommt dass wir alles
weggeschmissen aber wir haben keine
werkzeuge nichts behalten
die meisten wohl niemand hätte gedacht
dass kommt zurück
die schweizer uhrenindustrie
sie beherrscht die jahrzehntelang den
weltmarkt 95 prozent aller verkauften
uhren stammen anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts aus der schweiz
[Musik]
hergestellt in den jura telam
lange zeit eine erfolgsgeschichte die
schweizer uhrenindustrie zu beginn des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts vor und nach
dem ersten weltkrieg dominiert absolut
den weltmarkt es gibt konkurrenten in
den usa in frankreich noch nicht in
japan
aber die schweizer uhrenindustrie
dominiert den weltmarkt total die
schweizer uhrenmacher haben angst diesen
vorsprung zu verlieren damit die
ausländische konkurrenz nicht von ihrem
wissen profitieren kann er lässt der
bundesrat gesetze er verbietet den
export von unseren bestandteilen alles
wird geregelt wer wann wo in welcher
menge produziert alles gesetz quasi eine
planwirtschaft
anfangs geht alles gut die
uhrenindustrie organisiert in klein- und
kleinstbetriebe floriert dank staatlich
geregelten schutz
[Musik]
und so realisiert sie nicht dass ein
sturm aufzieht
[Musik]
denn die japanische uhrenindustrie hat
mittlerweile die schweizer uhren kopiert
und sie produziert hocheffizient
roboter ersetzen die hand montage
japan produziert zentralisiert nicht
zersplitterten kleinstbetriebe wie in
der schweiz
ernüchtert stolz das schweizer fernsehen
dieser apparat der die zeiger an presst
ist über 40 jahre alt die museums
würdigen maschinen werden immer noch bei
der schalen fertigung eingesetzt
man hat gesehen wie die umsätze ständig
stimmen die gefallen sind dass man
umsätze habt ihr nach oben gehende das
ist die schwankungen des ja noch mal im
leben aber hier
[Musik]
gleichzeitig löst die erdölkrise eine
weltweite rezession aus und die nächste
krise folgt gleich danach die
währungskrise der franken schnellt in
die höhe
die schweizer uhren sind plötzlich
doppelt so teuer
sie werden aus dem markt katapultiert in
den usa war ihm damals wichtigsten markt
für uhren werden die japanischen uhren
plötzlich günstiger als die
schweizerischen die extrem teuer sind
der faktor währung ist sehr wichtig
[Musik]
joja körpers nicht sogar haben franken
etwas was läuft in österreich auf das
los wenn man miterlebt
jeden morgen wissen sie nicht ob sie
überhaupt zur arbeit zurückkehren können
oder nicht
es gab viele entlassungen so habe ich es
damals erlebt nicht im finanzbereich
sucht tun ich habe eine enorme
verunsicherung erlebt und das war
ziemlich belastend für einen jungen
familienvater branche während fanny
[Musik]
dieses miteinander die schweizer
uhrenindustrie hat bekanntlich ihre
führende stellung auf dem bauch mehr
gibt als volk tv sind die schweiz ihre
letzten drei jahren rund 50.000
arbeitsplatz verloren in einer branche
wir sind ihr vorhin quasi für trubel
gehört sind für mich dass ich das was
die hehre wann und was sie erwartet uns
wenn wir jetzt mal alte
die allgemeine wirtschaftslage
nationalität x-mas nahmen vertreter von
roy der transfer neue boot nach dienten
zur tröstet spare vermietet was mir in
die leine nicht voll ausgenutzt und die
neue wohnung nicht voraus genutzte
fabrik und dadurch mit der konkurrenz
verheiratet die härteste konkurrenz
japanische uhr
sie werden maschinell produziert sind
viel günstiger und qualitativ gut
sie finden reißenden absatz innert fünf
jahren hat sich japans produktion
verdoppelt der ausstoß der schweizer
firmen dagegen stagnierte
wir haben gespürt dass das flugzeug an
höhe verliert und wir wer wir wussten
dass es nur eine lösung gibt wenn ein
flugzeug höhe verliert dann muss er mal
unten dass er wieder schwung kommt das
wieder die luft unter den flügel trägt
und dann über den hügel
das heißt wir wussten dass die lösung
kommt vom sparen aber nicht nur spaß
auch reorganisieren und eine neue oder
neue eine innovation zu bringen und
spüren wie sie das ist eine ganz
schlimme atmosphäre wenn man da arbeitet
und man jeden tag ist man konfrontiert
mit mit mit den selben probleme probleme
ich verkaufe nicht genügen
ich bekomme nicht genügend umsatz in die
kassen
[Musik]
es ist was mir jetzt oder machen dass
ich das kommt mir vor wie als langsames
ausbluten die abschiedssinfonie von
haydn was mir jetzt einen spieler
es wird musik gemacht aber als der wind
nimmervoll kein mensch hätte das wissen
[Musik]
in dieser krisenzeit sitzen die beiden
bankdirektoren in verwaltungsräten der
uhrenindustrie und beobachten das tanner
ich habe halt seines tagebuchs für die
ganze weltwirtschaft in schwierige
situation sie es hätte dort krise eine
cholerische abgewartet ots coface 50 und
aniston an die 70er jahre ist denn die
japanische industrie massiv billiger
koalition
[Musik]
die quarz krise der nächste schlag
japan wird zu dieser zeit die
elektronische uhr auf dem markt eine
revolution in der branche
die schweiz gerät weiter in rückstand
die jungen müssen
[Musik]
euro winken
man muss nicht vergessen
bis 1975 77 war die präzision ein
qualität ein qualitätsbeweis je mehr die
uhr präzis war
je teurer war sie auch
und plötzlich kommt eine japanische
firma sicon zum beispiel mit einem preis
der 70 prozent tiefer ist aber bessere
präzision natürlich es ist kein
amerikanischer es ist eine kurze aber
die leute haben gesagt auch präzis
präzis also haben sie irgendwie haben
die japaner es erreicht unser konzept
was auf präzision gebaut war haben sie
diese total zerstört weil sie kamen mit
relativ günstigen produkte und hatten
eine bessere qualität das heißt
präzision als die teuren zeit quelle ist
dieser quartz starb er schwingt über
32.000 mal pro sekunde und wird von
einer kleinst batterie gespeist hier nun
das revolutionär neue so sehen
integrierte schaltkreise unter dem
elektronenmikroskop aus sie wandeln die
schwingungen des quartz stabes und
addieren sie zu sekunden minuten stunden
und tagen
zwar fertig die schweizer uhrenindustrie
die erste serienmäßige quax uhr die beta
21 doch mit dem verkauf die schweizer
wissen ebenso gut wenn nicht besser als
die japaner wie man quarzuhren herstellt
aber was die japaner besser können ist
die vermarktung etwas produzieren dass
sich verkaufen lässt
die schweizer uhrenindustrie produziert
habe halt vorbei
die wahren lage fühlen sich mit
unverkäuflichen originalton damals im
kassensturz auf der champs élysées da
kauft man die besten uhren sagte uns ein
taxi chauffeur auf dem ganzen bull war
fanden wir aber nicht einen omega laden
dafür ein großes einkaufscenter
hier keine ladenhüter in den
schaufenstern nur neueste modell
ladenhüter hingegen sind die schweizer
uhren massive rabatte sind notwendig
swiss made ist kein wert mehr
[Musik]
man sagt das menschliche wesen beginnt
erst dann nachzudenken wenn es sich in
der not befindet die in dieser totalen
unsicherheit in der uhrenindustrie
müssen sie reagieren und sich fragen was
man tun kann
so war das klima damals klar um nachher
gibt es 10.000 versionen darüber wer der
patrona der befall eine uhr zu
entwickeln die nichts kostet und von
schweizer qualität ist das ist nicht
wichtig wichtig ist dass ich eine kleine
e kippe an die arbeit machen und
überlegte wie man dieses ziel an diesen
traum einer schweizer uhr die nichts
kostet verwirklichen könnte
[Musik]
noch gibt es einzig prototypen mit
vielen kinderkrankheiten
doch müller seekabel kann weiter
forschen
das ist ein schlüsselprodukt um die
märkte der industrieländer zu
attackieren
viele viele regisseure haben sich auf
mechanische uhren konzentriert an dieser
welt glaubten wir jungen nicht mehr
genug
wir glaubten diese welt sei tot für uns
waren das dampflokomotiven verglichen
mit dem diw die lokomotive
wir wollten nicht mehr mit
dampflokomotiven arbeiten so war die
lage damals in den 80er jahren
so heißt damals die eine konzern der die
schweizer uhrenindustrie dominiert ss
sias der andere
beide sind am ende freitag 28
februar die belegschaft wird kurzfristig
auf den späteren nachmittag zur
betriebsversammlung geladen
kurzarbeit für 13.500 arbeitnehmer bei
der us mutter aus
[Musik]
wie fällt nach weil die beiden
bankdirektoren erinnern sich
[Musik]
du hast ja schon im jahr eine nacht
intensiv wie schafft man es an ihre
quadratisch und hess das ganze prozedere
eigentlich klappt wo mir die nicht
versperrte das jahr später so artet es
richtig dass die fahrer haben also die
presse ja das ist meine agentur kna hahn
und gut getan wo könnte ich mich jetzt
freiburgs über einen beinbruch oder
sucht bisher in west und bitten alle
überrascht dass es relativ viele freie
chancen aber es ist noch einiges möglich
war wurde die iss ja hatte kein geld um
alleine weiter zu gehen
wir hatten erste probleme mit dem umsatz
mit der liquidität und sogar mit der
industrie also die es ja in meiner sicht
musste gerettet werden
es sind sehr viele arbeitsplätze auf dem
spiel
essen sie aß beschäftigt ungefähr 4000
leute also losgegangen ist dringend ein
überbrückungskredit zur verfügung
stellen die es ja ich nur dem stand die
dezember wir nach der zahler und so
schwartze bleibt
kurz darauf schlägt auch der
us-präsident bentley alarm im herbst
durch 80 millionen und nd sie relativ
schnell investiert braucht sie doch
eigentlich hätte sogar noch wörtlich
geschrieben
zunehmende preiszerfall die aufbauenden
überschwemmen den weltmarkt mit billigen
sehr genauen aber ziemlich hässlichen
krücken los
die asso aktiv auf die vfler und dann
haben wir gesagt ich möchte gerne
studios haben will will seiner frau
ingrid einfach zu locker wie das wie das
management weiter geht obwohl die heide
passt auch ein unternehmen war ganz gut
und richtig sexy aber weg findet dass
neben niederlange zum bei katastrophen
verhindert und darum haben wir im doktor
1 click set ist jetzt wissen wir es mal
vorwärts machen es muss man bis gar mehr
banken schon vor dass man jetzt vom
firma projekt engagiert zum studio zu
machen
der kreis studie worin raub als motiv
zeigt ist die firma nicolas g hayek
wurde als sohn eines zahnarztes in
beirut im libanon geboren seine
grundausbildung erhielt er an einer
französischen jesuitenschule
anschließend studierte hayek am sonntag
mathematik physik der universität lyon
wo er mit dem zertifikat des songs in
mathematik physik und chemie abschloss
sie wurden berater was haben sie dort
angetroffen
eine riesige menge erwartungen dass die
liebe gott uns hilft und eine totale
arroganz gegenüber anderen menschen
besser weil unsere ur großvater die
bessere ohren gemacht hat totale
erkenntnis der mentalität alle
unterbunden im haus dann das habe ich
sagen getroffen
die cherokee klartext in die andere sie
ist vom morgigen 80
übrigens auch diskus achse
touristikleiter ganz hervorragend aber
herrscht diskussion prof und das ist
also drunter und drüber gegangen und die
weiten wege mehr als eigentlich schreibe
des verwendeten technik ist die witwe
und den hätte peter alberts halt um was
gehts mir hän das schema das ist d mark
wenden wo man seit einer marke sind
omega und logis marke tissot mido etc
und sie machen sich die aufkommende die
heiße die papier stein am rhein berg ein
flipchart flipcharts und dannheimer
wieder wittenbecher treffen denn gottes
will die organisationsstruktur es gibt
drei varianten eine mini der mx variante
mit der mx jungfrau und die variante
maxi das ist varianten noch nicht alles
unter einer kutte die schweizer
uhrenindustrie war verzettelt ihm sie in
jede marke war für sich alleine
die meisten gehört dann auch zu
privatleute da kam der große hype klar
und er sagte wir müssen alle unter einem
dach
und wenn wir alle diese marken und
lieferanten unter einem dach bringen
dann haben wir stärker dann haben wir
natürlich auch die mengen und dann
können wir industriell gegen die japaner
etwas tun denn am schluss nach den zwei
tage stehen
in präziseren umriss euro was man
nachher gemacht hätte aber hufe detail
haben nach einer klaren damals häufig
gewartet hast das klingt am schluss die
definitiv verstehen mich zu dem
sanierungspaket von widerstand kein
privates radford große die
industrievertreter kontakt mir sie
krämpfe dass dir zustimmen und die
strategie unter derart schwammig ist
auch die möglichkeit ihre boni leitete
damals das staatssekretariat für
wirtschaft seco bondi hatte als
bundesvertreter das drama persönlich
miterlebt
damals schreibt er eine geheime notiz an
den bundesrat
der toni moser da waren grob katja den
klassiker wie vor frisches obst
entscheiden ob das gelingt und drei
musiker die die ganze fusion zusatzakku
und als standort wo es weiter passiert
mit picknick blume war dabei war also
die uhr industrie aus der schweiz
verschwunden
sein blick behalten heute und jetzt und
in diesem fall geht es darum dass die
banken einen betrag von 116 millionen
franken abschreiben müssen so sachlich
und nüchtern hätte es härter der
pressekonferenz und der bank of korea
sensational abschluss bekommt hacker
guten wetter land sensationell gehört
wir unter die familie vor der banken zur
verfügung stellt war er damit dass die
sanierung überhaupt sondern abschluss
kommt und sensationell auch wenn die
fusion vertragswerk und reststoffen
gigant schaffte und mit der größten in
japan ohne wii besitzer konkurrenzfähig
sagt diese banken seien
das ist ein eckball zwar streng ich sie
und fasst das wunder dass das stark mit
schlussendliche berühmten bank um 3 kurz
bringen sie mehr bei wenigen zigarette
oder zwingen mitmach bank erhält ihr
handy für beide filme gerettet
[Musik]
doch so groß wie beurteilen sie die
mittelfristigen zukunftsaussichten er
optimistisch auch wenn der weg noch lang
ist wie hat dass er bis bringen
es bringe sich
was stellen sie sich vor ein abo
arbeitsplatz diese kritiker wirklich
bringt
wir rechnen nicht damit dass in nächster
zeit oder auch auf mittlere frist
größere betriebsschließungen noch
notwendig sind management abbau
bearbeitet das bringt ja weitaus mehr
der tat häufig dinge selbstverständlich
müssen in allen organisationseinheiten
die dinge noch optimiert werden was
vielleicht dem einen oder anderen noch
zu geringen abbaumaßnahmen führen kann
[Musik]
dass die stücke mit sehr viel engagement
mit sehr viel geld wenig dass man das
nachher wie der industrielle handhabe
für die immer breiter publikum passiere
passiere was auch immer und tätern in
dem möbelstück rechte rand hätte drei ex
lover 60 millionen privatwaldbesitzer &
börse ist nicht meine sache ja die pet
große bereich eines schönen tages
aufblühte und hector die hayek
geschäftsstelle interessiert wie sollte
die operetten unternehmer die stoffe und
dann hätte mir tausend cloud wird ist
stark und ich finde das sollte mache
[Musik]
ich glaube an das ungewöhnliche das
passieren kann ich glaube dass ein
wunder kann passieren ich habe geglaubt
dass man der uhrenindustrie werden wir
richtig etwas machen da wird ein wunder
passieren ich bin nicht von anfang an
bis sie mich der gesagt hat das geht
nicht mehr fertig hören wir auf im
gegenteil ich bin wie ein kind voller
hoffnung voller träume volle vorstellung
hier in der fassade aber dreikönigstraße
eine 20 meter im finanzplatz zürich sie
wichtige entscheide sache uhrenindustrie
gefoult wurde hörte ich immer die lecks
in der bekanntgabe oder das so mit der
führung von nicolas hayek 51 prozent vom
ehemaligen mutterkonzern der besitzer
wechselte kritiker bank gmbh egg das für
eine schnäppchen dass politiker sich
aber sehr jahr aber damals gar nicht
damals man hätte ja nicht fest klingt
die sache überhaupt auf das wetter es
ist was günstiges angebot sie aus
heutiger sicht und das damalige sich
sogar ein faires angebot
aber das ist kein geschenk
[Musik]
kippe
loben sie die ganze mannschaft und sie
sind durch die wie viel spaß ja wir
arbeiten 8
[Musik]
ich glaube was ich machen kann die das
übertragen die menschen um ihr glaube
daran und macht mit storys klar ist mir
wirklich nicht vom stuhl
also er hat er zur atlanta feature
innere sache mit der normalen sich das
ist die kinder das hat es hat kesha
entspricht
natürlich kommt das verein soll wieso
macht sie hat gelernt wenn wir die
richtige uhrzeit so ich dass nichts
verkauft das ist der ganze langweiligen
uhr
[Musik]
die buche produkte im unteren
marktsegment damit ihr gegen die japaner
kämpfen
als ingenieure waren wir sicher ob das
stimmt wohl auch wir haben ein perfektes
produkt kreiert und ich glaube auch
heute sind die menschen zufrieden mit
der swatch dir gut läuft und wenig
kostet ein gutes produkt zu haben ist
eines zu verkaufen ist etwas anderes und
erfolg zu haben nochmal ist etwas
anderes
ich sage zu hause immer ich kann eine
gute suppe kochen aber damit erfolg zu
haben
renault mid zu haben das schaffe ich
nicht kann mir ganz gut erinnern dass
wir damals gesehen haben dass dieses
wort als technische wunder nicht zu
erklären ist ein problem das publikum im
ausland hat überhaupt kein interesse
daran wie viel zeit ist sie in einen ohr
haben sie wollen ein junior haben die
funktioniert und daraufhin haben wir
gewusst wir müssen diese uhr eine seele
geben
und dort haben wir das war keine seele
gegeben das heißt eine botschaft
[Musik]
die uhr ist nicht mehr ein produkt das
die zeit anzeigt sondern ein mode
artikel
es ist das erste mal in der schweiz dass
man einen modeartikel hat für die breite
masse und so verkauft man sie auch es
ist in der uhrenindustrie der beginn des
storytellings die uhr dient als mittel
um geschichten zu erzählen eine
geschichte für das publikum
für die journalisten und andere eine
geschichte die über die uhr hinausgeht
eine swatch ist nicht mehr eine uhr die
die zeit anzeigt sondern etwas cooles
sportliches und gestützt darauf beginnt
man zu kommunizieren
er hat sicher das potenzial der swatch
gespürt deshalb hat er auch seine
eigenen finanziellen mittel investiert
er hat daran geglaubt dieser marke hat
er immer gegenüber anderen bevorzugt
das ist auch heute war seine sohn der
fall der mich eingeschlossen natürlich
dieser marke bevorzugt dollar
warum habe ich angefangen mit sword wir
hatten 90 fabriken mit 6000 arbeiter die
gar keine arbeit hatten um ihn herum und
löcherte das heißt ich hätte keine
alternative gehabt außer diese zu
schließen und der gesamte know how der
schweiz zu verlieren wenn wir aber eine
uhr basieren würden die mehr als 100.000
pro jahr verkauft oder 200 und 300
sondern in die millionen geht und wir
haben gehofft dass sie in die millionen
gehen dann hätten wir diese fabriken zu
haben wir gemacht
[Musik]
das hat selbst ein mensch mit derartige
rasche auffassungsgabe mit der
kombinations klappt er seit siebzig
gegebenes papier verteilt wurde nicht
ich denke ganz schwierig so schmidhofer
zahle dann ist peter langsamste glaub
ich aber komisch das papier auf dem
tisch vom 1
das wird verdammt noch mal hat das linke
hindernis haben wir nie überwinden wenn
man sie nicht vorher an und warum das
hier zeigen zwei techniker der hanna und
sie sehr gefiel mir aus nie für immer
machen aber dass ich mit dieser linie um
politik machen was ist sehr groß
schwächen sehr ungesund wenn er
umfassend ich um geduld gegeben im
geschäft ja kein geduld mit liebevoller
nette menschen die einfach defizit poker
tour bis verstehen und die hat geduld
mit der pilot ohne gott kraft gegen berg
dazu neben sofort ersetzen wenn der
gefahr sehr groß ist für den flug zu
wissen sie wenn sie kreativ sind
die innovativ sind wenn sie lernfähig
sehen und wenn sie neugierig sind gilt
sie ja nur nach vorne
es gibt keinen anderen weg
nicolas hayek setzt nicht nur auf die
swatch zusammen mit jean claude biver
passierte auch die teuren mechanischen
uhren
das wird der zweite weg aus der krise
mit jung war
die haben natürlich den den plan
hightech gesehen die effizienz und die
unglaubliche meister idee von hayek zu
sagen ich muss zuerst der das untere
segment wieder stark machen dass ich
eine starke basis bekomme da sich auch
im niedrigen preissegment die anzahl die
quantitäten habe um dann darauf eine
pyramide die dann bis ganz oben geht zu
bauen und das hat natürlich nicht
unbedingt jeder verstanden
und da es war eine absolute geniale idee
von durchweg positiv
die kunst geht weiter
indem sie die vergangenheit immer nach
vorne bringen und das ist die ewigkeit
und wir haben dann gesagt wir machen
eine ökologische und eine ökologische
uhr ist eine uhr die keine elektronik
besitz und die nur mit dem handgelenk
sich auf zieht das ist ja wunder dass
ist das wunderwerk das ist denn die
beste erfindung die es gibt mit meinem
körper der sich bewegt bringt energie in
das objekt ja was wollen sie besser das
ist er das und das war unser
leidenschaft und da haben wir immer
darauf gespielt ehrlichkeit
amerikanischen ist gehweg
[Musik]
seine vision ermöglicht die renaissance
der schweizer uhrenindustrie weniger
uhren dafür aber teurere japanische
uhren sind heute auf dem weltmarkt
praktisch bedeutungslos heute kennt die
uhrenbranche das potenzial das marketing
es ist nicht mehr eine frage der
industrie sondern man muss die uhren
verkaufen können ihnen mit einer guten
markenpolitik einen wert hinzufügen und
sich nicht einzig auf diesen
hervorragenden restrukturierten
industrie apparat zu stützen sondern auf
die marken die diesen nutzen das
industrielle problem ist gelöst
man bewegt sich jetzt zum nächsten
problem zum wertzuwachs wie er einer
markenpolitik dort stehen wir jetzt und
dieses muster hat sich bewährt und der
schweizer uhrenindustrie erlaubt ihre
kompetitive position zu stärken
im jahr 2010 stirbt nicolas g hayek
seine nachkommen hatte bereits zu
lebzeiten führungsaufgaben übertragen
sie kontrollieren mit dem sogenannten
hayek pool die swatch-gruppe seine
kinder leiten wollte das unternehmen
[Musik]
seit der machtübernahme der familie
hayek über die swatch-gruppe leben wir
sicher man muss arbeiten neues
entwickeln aber was die arbeitsmoral und
die sicherheit des arbeitsplatzes
betrifft so leben wir im paradies
seit der ankunft das ist unbestreitbar
[Musik]
mehr sie ist jetzt bereits geändert ob
sie das ist positiv sieht man herrn
geselligkeit aus möglichst schnell in
die hand als bank banker welche immer
nur der firma führen bisher frog sie
darum dass das nicht passieren
das wünsche ich natürlich noch möglich
gegangen
sie hätte glauben wiederholt zurück doch
die schweizerische uhrenindustrie kritik
sie die swatch group mir könnte von
japan ist es noch ganz gelungenen
streich sie will diese völlig baff dass
es der ruinen und wo nötig und besser
als das was macht eigentlich neue
geschmack von design und das heißt es
überhaupt geschafft
[Musik]
er ist hat uns den courts industrie die
zwei die japaner haben uns zerstört
haben die mechanische uhr kaputt
geschlagen
wir kamen zurück mit dem hai plan und
haben gesagt wir machen auch kurz
schweizer kurz aber zurückhaltend
das war die swatch und die hat dann die
japaner total umgebracht später kamen
wir dann wieder zurück
nicht-amerikanischen uhr und heute ist
amerikanische uhr der king der schweizer
uhrenindustrie
[Musik]